large crowds of protesters angry over a
deadly police shooting shut down a major
highway near Pittsburgh overnight the
protest halted traffic for hours it
marked the second day of unrest
following Tuesday's shooting of an
unarmed teen cell phone video shows
Antoine Rose jr. running from police
before he was shot
Ricca Duncan is outside the Allegheny
County Courthouse in Pittsburgh where
yesterday's protests began
shreeka good morning good morning it was
largely peaceful here Thursday afternoon
but those crowds grew confrontational at
times by nightfall
protestors say that they want justice
for Antoine Rose as we now learn more
about the officer who opened fire on
them protesters faced off against police
says they halted traffic on a major
interstate for over five hours Thursday
night it was the culmination of the day
of rallies and demonstrations across the
city
I'm thinking that the cops should be
held accountable I'm thinking - Antoine
should be here he should have been
killed cell phone video shows Antoine
Rose jr. running away from police as he
was shot three times police say the car
Rose was in matched the description of a
vehicle involved in a drive-by shooting
Tuesday night two weapons were found in
the car according to the County District
Attorney Rose was unarmed but was
carrying an empty handgun clip the
driver of the car was questioned and
released another suspect is still at
large
the officer involved has been identified
as Michael Ross felt he was sworn into
the department about 90 minutes before
the deadly shooting but he had been on
duty in East Pittsburgh for three weeks
and has been an officer elsewhere in the
region since 2011 sources say he was
hospitalized after the incident and
later released the family's attorney
says the demonstrations are helping
roses relatives heal that family is
really hurting right now
[Music]
part of the protest it lets them know
that the community is hurting with them
[Applause]
officer Ross Feld is on paid leave as
authorities conduct an independent
investigation into what exactly happened
now a local station did speak to officer
Ross Feld and he said that he's received
a lot of support from fellow officers
and also that he did not know about the
cell phone video that captured the
shooting gale so a lot of questions here
thank you very much dareka